let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well good wednesday afternoon everybody
[Music]
it is three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern you know what time that is
on wednesdays it's time to talk
so let's talk thanks for joining me here
at the tony michaels podcast
it's june 23rd and we are going to have
a special guest today
there is a little bit of technical
difficulty for now
but i'm going to try to buy him about 15
maybe 20 minutes if he can hear me out
there
to get connected to his wi-fi he's
having a little bit of trouble
connecting so once we get him connected
we'll bring him in
and you guys all know who this guest is
we've had him on before i think this is
his third time on i believe
sam is this his third time on if she can
hear me
and we might be having more technical
difficulties than i thought but i think
this is his third time on
this is the third time on uh his name is
michael j and he's at one black man's
opinion over on tick tock
and he's at dubnew world order
on twitter if you're watching on twitter
and i've got all the links
up there on the tweets and we'll throw
some clips up
and i'll make sure you get over to his
account what happened was
is last week the federal government the
senate decided to go ahead and vote
to pass juneteenth and president biden
signed it into law and we had
juneteenth that's a new holiday well
michael j
at one black man's opinion over on tick
tock he decided to make a video about it
and when he made a video about it you
know how he does
he says things in a certain way
it makes a certain people want to spread
it around the internet
so his video ends up on a duet which
ends up on dl hewley's instagram page
which in turn in turn that video
shows up that video shows up
on leslie jones's twitter
account which the reason why i noticed
it is because i was scrolling through my
feed and
bam there's a [ __ ] hat michael j had
the [ __ ] hat on
here's a great one i've got a black one
on but here's a great one he had a
[ __ ] hat on
which was fantastic but the content was
even better
and the opinions the opinion was even
better
so we're going to talk about that once
we get michael j
in a position in the next 15 minutes or
so when he starts giving me the thumbs
up that he's got wi-fi
he's good to go and he's good we'll
bring him on and we're going to talk
about that video
more importantly we're going to talk
about juneteenth
and his opinions on juneteenth which
will probably lead us into things like
critical race theory which i want to
talk about today because
the joint chief general mark milley had
a little
bit of an opinion a couple hours ago in
a committee hearing
about critical race theory that everyone
should go [ __ ] listen to
because mark milly decides to tell
everyone what critical race theory
actually is not what people want to
think it is
what it actually is and you may not
agree with the opinion you may or may
not but
he has a good little sound bite there to
tell everyone
sit down and shut the [ __ ] up so i like
that
speaking of the word [ __ ] speaking of
where everyone knows
that is my superhuman ability is the
word [ __ ]
it is now the word [ __ ] is now
constitutionally protected the supreme
court of the united states
decided that the word [ __ ]
is protected by the constitution
it is set in stone folks [ __ ] them
forever
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em and it's
constitutional they can't take that away
from me
they're basically sanctioning my [ __ ]
logo i mean that's the way i wanna see
it
that may not be exactly the way it is
but you know i get to frame things
here on my podcast and that's how i want
to frame it
is that my logo is now constitutionally
protected by the supreme court and the
laws of the land
freedom liberty [ __ ] um
that's how i see it so the word [ __ ] is
constitution predicted so i'm sure we'll
get into that
we'll talk about that a little bit and
speaking of constitutional rights
and what you had right right what not to
do we seen yesterday
that 50 gop senators
voted to not debate
the voting rights bill the for the
people act
they drew the mulligan card they use the
filibuster which
that's a whole another ball of wax that
we're probably going to get into
if we get michael j back on here it's
about the voting right the for the
people act the voting rights
law that came to the senate floor and
they blocked the debate
now just to be clear so people
understand how a law is made
because trump pumpers and manga people
don't understand how laws are made
they just blocked the debate of the bill
that's it they didn't block the bill i
mean it blocks the bill because now it
can't go to the floor
to be debated and then voted on cloture
and then voted to vote for the actual
bill to become a law there are several
votes to get through
on the floor to get this thing to
president biden's desk
because it was hr one um this is eight
this is s1 or sb1 or
whatever initials you want to give it
now it was hr1
so this is the voting rights bill that
came out of the house
um it is a very pretty comprehensive
bill
on how to not [ __ ] with our vote
it's a building block it's a start it's
not really uh
not everything and it's fantastic not
everything's put together
just right but it is a start
the best part is is if you pair it with
the john lewis voting rights act
it makes it even stronger because
basically the john lewis voting rights
act even though it's a different bill
it kind of undoes all the stuff that the
supreme court undid
with the voting rights act the original
one you know
the one that they shouldn't have taken
away
which everyone's talking about uh
republicans suppressing the vote and all
these laws there's several hundred laws
being passed in these state legislators
to
uh to suppress the vote and when i mean
suppress the vote
i don't mean just taking people off the
rolls
i mean actually trying to prevent
people from going and voting
okay not not just not just taking them
off the rolls these are registered
voters
that they are trying to put hurdles in
their way that makes it more difficult
to
vote
way beyond what votier voter id could
ever
imagine doing i mean we're talking about
making it criminal
to hand someone a bottle of water who's
standing in line waiting to vote for
five hours seven hours eight hours
whatever because they're thirsty
right we're also talking about
precedes that have a million voters
having the same amount of drop boxes as
that have ten thousand precincts that
have ten thousand
which seems a little out of whack
they're trying to
set hurdles in place to make it harder
to vote
so that's why we need to put pressure
on not just republicans but by god we
need to put pressure on republicans
here and that is a a very very very very
key to put pressure on them but also we
need to put pressure
on christian cinema and joe manchin
and the reason why is because the
republicans
would kill the bill to kill voting
rights
excuse me the republicans would kill the
filibuster
to kill voting rights hear me when i say
this
mitch mcconnell the republican party
would do away with the filibuster
if it meant getting rid of all voters
that won't vote for them
100 percent full stop mitch mcconnell
the gqp
the gop the q anon maga trump bumpers
would get rid of the filibuster if it
meant they could pass a law to make sure
the people who don't like their policies
couldn't vote for them that's what it
that's they would do that
they would get rid of the filibuster in
a [ __ ] heartbeat
just like they got rid of the filibuster
with their judges
the supreme court judge
hello hello think mcfly
think of course the republicans would
get rid of the filibuster
of course they would why wouldn't they
press their ideas on us now on the same
hand democrats
want to get rid of the filibuster so
that everyone can vote
everyone everybody
rather you vote for democrats
libertarian green party republicans
whoever you're voting for they want
to have to where everyone can vote kill
the filibuster
pass the voting rights bill so everyone
gets the chance to vote
everyone gets to put their seal of
approval on the politicians that are
making policy for
us but they don't want that they don't
want that because that would mean that
the
majority would rule in this country and
they would lose power
that's what it means that's why they
don't want to end the filibuster now
and i mean they the republicans the
manga trump up and q anon
gop who what
we could go on and evangelical
christians we could go on and on and on
with descriptions of these people
they do not want to kill the filibuster
right now
in this moment in time because if they
if it the filibuster is killed in this
moment of time
we get the for the people act we get the
john lewis voting rights act
and republicans are right when they say
if we pass it i've seen ted cruz if we
pass this bill
if we pass this bill republicans won't
get reluctant for a hundred years
because they won't change their ideas or
their party platform
because they're [ __ ] dumb yeah of
course you shitbags won't get elected
anything no one
your policies and your ideas [ __ ]
suck and everyone
knows it everyone knows that your ideas
suck
so much so that your own party your
[ __ ] platform for the 2020 is gonna
be
hunter biden's laptop that's how bad
your ideas are
hunter ben la hunter biden's laptop is
your platform that's how
[ __ ] bad your ideas are so
the next topic that i want to touch on
today too sorry about the tangent but
you know we got to buy time for mr
michael j here
i think he's almost ready but the next
topic that i want to go over today
is the january 6 commission because i
believe that this is some of the most
significant news
that has come out of washington dc in
the last week
uh is that it sounds like there's a
little bit of a rumbling
that nancy pelosi is going to
form a select committee very similar to
the benghazi committee
which i believe the democrats didn't
want to do necessarily and i don't think
the republicans this is a great option
for them either
but we'll talk about how that's gonna go
and what that means and how it means for
politics and how it could affect
the 2020 race possibly possibly
and i think michael j is almost ready
give me a thumbs up
are you ready all right he's ready folks
we got michael j at one black man's
opinion all this stuff that i just been
yammering on about
we're going to get his opinion on all
this stuff all of it
but what i want to start out with i want
to start with this juneteenth video that
he did
where it kind of went it went viral
let's just say it went viral when you
end up on dl dlugly's page on instagram
and you end up on less dogs leslie
jones's twitter
twitter page you're you're viral at that
point
not not it is a viral video
okay now i don't actually have the video
because it was hard for me to pull the
video
um but i i want to quote him
a few times here before i bring him on
because in the video he says
and maybe he could correct me when he
comes on because i want to make sure i'm
right here
he says about the juneteenth holiday he
says
who gives a [ __ ] which by the way is a
constitutionally protected word now
he says who gives a [ __ ] he says in the
video he also says the reason why he
gives a [ __ ]
is because republicans are trying to
stop people from voting in texas
places like texas and texas
and he he he assumes that republicans
voting for this thing is placation
so i'm sure he'll tell us about his his
opinion on placation with this
hotness new holiday and
he assumes that it's just a you know
a thing where they're placating so that
republicans
tell black people hey just be quiet go
away now we gave you your holiday
that's what he says in the video and the
reason why he knows all this
is because he's got the t-shirt and the
[ __ ] jacket
so i don't know if he's got that t-shirt
on right now but let's bring
let's bring michael jay in on the
conversation
how you doing sir i ain't wearing a
t-shirt but i'm wearing a [ __ ] hat
[ __ ] up i love it i love it
so so i so i i take it i bought you
enough time to uh get your
i've been here for i've been here for
for about 10
minutes okay good good we were real
close to home dude like
the hospital right up the street so i
just i just wanted to make sure that you
had enough time to get on your wi-fi and
get set up
so i appreciate baby we're good i
appreciate you
joining me today so did i get everything
right about the uh about
about the video let's let's talk for a
second first of all
if i thought for 2.5 seconds that that
passing another bank holiday
would stop black men from getting shot
down in the street would shock black
women
from getting shot in their beds where uh
stop black children from getting shot in
playgrounds for playing with a toy gun
i'd say hey
kudos but guess what it's not going to
change a [ __ ] thing
okay and you've got two bills you've got
the anti-lynching bill you got the
anti-hate bill
sitting on a desk and what you give me
is juneteen
now what really pisses me off about this
and yes i do think it's placation
because they do want black people to
stop
talking see when when when
when george floyd got murdered that was
viral
that video was viral and
there's no going back from that
so what people are going to have to
start dealing with the fact is that
black people are asking for things that
everybody else gets
that's all and when we ask it's it's
it should be an immediate response 400
plus years
of mistreatment of unjustice injustice
excuse me
of of just being treated wrong
and to know that the bills are there
and you're in in your infinite wisdom
you go
happy bank holiday
i'm i'm sorry i'm i'm i'm really
confused here i thought the idea was we
were going to take make things better
for black people i want to know
how making june juneteenth a federal
holiday
makes things better for black people i
understand it's a landmark decision i
understand that it it
it puts it it carves in stone
the date however
what it's all about how we got there
they don't want to teach
that so why did you bother making it a
holiday
because you want black people to shut
the [ __ ] up
and it don't come and that's going to be
my opinion until somebody proves me
wrong
okay because that's exactly what i see
if you really wanted to do right by
black people
the anti-lynching bill would have been
signed up they run out
happy bank holiday it's like it's like
take a crumb put up the world's smallest
[ __ ] candle
and go happy birthday to you [ __ ] you
dude
are you serious come on man
it's just another it's another it's just
something else
like black history month so
yippee i i i knew if i gave you a
microphone
dude that's something else that bothers
me black history month it's [ __ ]
history
right it's not black history it's
american it's american it's
it's not even it's history it's not even
american history
it's [ __ ] history
so so i so i so i've said this on this
podcast before
and i can't wait for the day
when because uh you remember when uh joe
biden
he he undid the ban of trans soldiers in
the military
and everyone's like oh yeah i'm like yay
that shouldn't be a should be like yeah
that's [ __ ] common sense what the
[ __ ] why are we
why why why why why is that this should
not be a big
it should be a yeah they should be
they're human beings
they should be able if they're
able-bodied they should be able to do
whatever the [ __ ] job they want to do
and it should not be a big deal it
always debates me as
a heterosexual man to to to be around my
other heterosexual man and see how they
re
how they act around gay men or trans men
i'm just like
i'm like dude why are you tripping it's
just like
man you know i ain't trying to be around
no fact i'm like what you're afraid
you're gonna slip dude
you might see somebody you thought was
cute well don't you don't you think
though don't you think though that that
that's the same sentiment i think that's
what you're saying with this june teen
thing it's the same sentiment for white
people right
that because here here's what i'll tell
you being a white person i told you this
earlier on the phone
that i did not know what juneteenth was
and i was talking to another one of my
white friends and i said do you know why
we don't know why juneteenth is he said
oh we didn't learn in school i saw
[ __ ]
give me a break it's not that we didn't
learn we we know a lot of [ __ ] that we
weren't taught in school never learned
in school
exactly i'd know a lot of [ __ ] that i
wouldn't talk some [ __ ] i shouldn't know
that i wasn't taught in school reason
why we didn't know what juneteenth was
until now is because we're white
we're white that's why we didn't know
that's why we didn't know
that's why and and and that's why they
want
to to they don't want juneteen
if they don't what they don't want
critical race theory to be thought and
and
and here's i guess maybe it's the title
maybe because they call it critical race
theory maybe that's the thing that
scares
people to death but it's like look we
just want you to understand that racism
is is inherited within the system it's
it's
literally woven in to the tapestry
of this country and that's why [ __ ] is
the way it is
and nobody's trying to teach white
children that they should hate
themselves
no one's trying to teach them we want
you to understand why it is
your father hates little joshua's father
because he's black
that's what we want to teach you we want
to teach you why it is that police
officers are shooting black people in
the street
we want to show you why that is they
don't want
any reality dude you've got people out
here still think columbus discovered a
mirror
okay no seriously and that's the sad
[ __ ] part is you've got people out
here so
dim that they still believe something
that's already been disproven
it it it's it's it's i i i swear to god
i i go to tick-tock dude and i'm like i
how are you still breathing and be that
stupid
because you still think that somehow
some way donald trump is going to be
president again
that's a that's a a a daily thought for
you and it brings you
joy and you think you can come on tick
tock and go nanny
boo boo donald trump's gonna be
president you'll see
and we're all supposed to go oh darn
dude
he's literally no longer in the [ __ ]
white house
there's literally someone else living
there
there's literally someone else there
calling president
you [ __ ] cannot let go of this
[ __ ] fantasy
that he's just gonna come right into the
[ __ ] rescue and right all the wrongs
and
stop all those bad things that you don't
agree with like critical race theory
critical race theory well you know you
know what's crazy so so did you have you
seen the clip yet and i know i know you
were busy today
uh with some uh some stuff in the
hospital i'm making a slight adjustment
here to the light
no that's fine yeah because i'm like
blowing out the screen here
so so i know you were busy but
uh joint chief mark milley was in a
committee hearing
yes and i don't know if you've seen this
clip i haven't seen it i
you you're the first person to tell me
about that yeah so so
they're talking about critical race
theory being taught at the military
academy right
uh critical and he he explains what
critical race theory is
in his answer which is beautiful he says
look critical race theory is a law
theory
it's it's the analysis of systematic
racism inside of laws
and it's the study of it in a law school
and in a college
so it's not being taught critical race
theory isn't being taught to elementary
kids number one
because it that's not what it is uh but
they like those buzzwords
critical race theory you know it's got
all that race is your buzzword
oh yeah well critical oh it sounds like
we must
we must be black and we must be black
now
you know what i mean it's real scary for
these white people it's critical as in
we're going to criticize
everyone who isn't black that's right
that's it too
well i mean however you want to frame it
up however you want to frame
we're just going to be a and again
if if because this is the thing at the
end of the day that i confess
just if you want change cool
but stop pretending you want it when you
don't
okay if you want things to be better for
everyone
okay then then i'll roll with you in all
lives matter but
but you don't even believe that [ __ ] you
don't believe all lives matter when you
say it you anybody out there using that
phrase all live matter you don't [ __ ]
believe that [ __ ]
you're part of a group of people trying
desperately to hang on to 1955.
i don't know why that is but well you
know what yes i do
because the world was overly white then
everything was white in 1955
everything and as the world became a
little more brown and a little more
brown
yeah i remember when things used to be
different
translation i remember there used to be
more white people
well i mean i mean that's and i said
this earlier that i think donald trump
is the last two raw here
for these the white evangelical
christians that's why
like you said earlier they can't let him
go they can't let him go because he is
their last hurrah it's their last chance
it's the last opportunity that they got
to perpetuate this lie
yes nonsense he is literally all they
have which is why they are clinging to
him like a drowning man trying to hold
on to a toothpick
it is a saddest [ __ ] thing dude they
this man is bringing nothing to the
table just like the gop
he has nothing he is offering nothing
except conjecture
bumper sticker slogans and [ __ ] and
people are
buying into this end mask because they
don't want to deal with the reality
that the world is actually changing
people talk all the time
things need to change because when
things actually start to change
people go i don't want things to change
well it's too [ __ ] late
change is a is is an inevitable part of
life
no matter who the [ __ ] you are who you
voted for what your religion
is what your sexual preferences are
change comes
to us to everybody so you all gonna have
to start getting with this thing
that that critical race theory is
something
that that matter of fact
white people in general need to
understand matt mckinnon so let me just
go ahead and say this
to black people white people to everyone
in general when it comes to the
discussion of race
we are all going to have to sit down and
have a very long
and uncomfortable discussion
a lot of things are going to be sad a
lot of people are going to get their
butt hurt but you know what
if you all really want to fix [ __ ]
you're going to have to start dealing
with everybody's issues
and rather than shoot somebody down when
they're expressing themselves let them
get it out let them land the [ __ ]
plane dude
then go ahead and comment but but but
people people don't want to
to you know it's and
it gets so frustrating for me because
there's so much crap going on in my hand
on a consistent date on a consistent
level
daily so when i try to sort through all
this and somebody asks me a question i
try to i do my best not to [ __ ]
branch the [ __ ] off so i apologize if
i'm tanging
tangenting i'm on a tangent there you go
and
it it i just get frustrated at the fact
that people
consistently talk about change but when
it comes to the actual
act the actual commitment the actual
here's what we're going to do to affect
change people can't do it now the whole
george floyd thing that was out that was
out of
that happened you were gonna stop you
could have stopped that if you wanted to
we had global protests for some [ __ ]
that happened in america
global
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] came to a head at that
day and and
critical race theory is is and the the
sad part about it is
is is they think critical race theory is
somehow the end it is the beginning
right whole bunch of of educated people
and again that is they're
they do not want an educated populist
they do not want people capable of
critical [ __ ] thinking
operate the machines and do what we tell
you that's what they want they don't
want people to have an opinion
about [ __ ] it is just well if we have an
opinion that we have to listen to you
and if we have to listen to you then we
have to act like we [ __ ] care we
don't want to [ __ ] do that it's just
easier for us
you see how the republicans are now dude
they don't even give a [ __ ]
they don't even give a [ __ ] that they're
corrupt they're corrupt right out in
public
and they don't give two shits because
they know
that clock is ticking i mean i mean in
florida to give you an example because
you mentioned a couple things in that
video about texas and and other states
voting laws
uh georgia bans water and voting lines
florida does basically the same thing
florida today did you hear that ron
desantis
writes writes a bill that you have to
take a
you have to take a [ __ ] survey when
you enter college of what your political
affiliations are
so that way they can diversify colleges
based on your political affiliation no
no that way there's a diversified right
is that the word you're using diverse
so they can diverse i love the word they
use so we can diversify right
so they so they can make it diverse so
you can know who the [ __ ] to target
that's it you want to [ __ ] leave
alone of course man
come on oh my god so so here
so so here's so i so i was talking to
a teacher a high school teacher friend
of mine
and i was asking about critical race
theory
i said have you ever heard this [ __ ]
word before he's been a teacher for
like 15 years right like have you ever
heard this [ __ ] word these words
before he's like not
not since like just recently and he said
and and all the teachers are running
around going i'm not teaching critical
race here he's like what are you talking
about
it's taught in law schools you're not
teaching critical race theory
in elementary your second grade
elementary class calm the [ __ ] down
yeah right so so so he
right so i was asking him i was asking
him
about you know like students and
because the only time that someone's
going to be exposed to critical race
theory is if they go to law school or if
they go to a university where they're
going to study something
where critical race theory is part of
the curriculum
right right and so so i was like
so i was asking him because he he's
taught in a lot of
all white schools very rural missouri
schools
and i said i said how many of your
students would you think
believe a certain thing when they
graduate high school
and when you see them four five six
years later they're a completely
different
person and and the reason he said he
said it's
almost nine nine out of ten and he said
sometimes
sometimes those people are completely
different people
sometimes those people just know the
truth and are unwilling to say it
because they come back to podunk white
usa
there you go but but the thing that is
the thing that is
is prominent he said is that when these
kids
go to college and experience actual
diversity
like you know different religions
different culture
different race different sexualities
they find out that these all the stuff
they've been fed is [ __ ]
right it's all lies it you shouldn't be
afraid of these things
these things did different different
is good like
like different is good it's not bad
it's a good thing right that's right
it and and the only thing that defines
you
and i think that's what he was trying to
get at was the only thing that defines
you in your life is your experiences
and if you if you don't experience
but only one thing in your life that's
all you will ever be
why do you think we have a bunch of
white people who are scared you can't be
white
because that's all they've ever
experienced if they would experience
other culture
other things other people yeah they
wouldn't be they they wouldn't be scared
of their whiteness and it being taken
away you can't take away people's
whiteness jesus christ
i'm a crusty you know that i'm a saltine
cracker
for [ __ ] sake you can't take that away
from me
you can't take that away from me but you
know something it
how long have you been you know it's all
about you're going to take this from
this it's going to take america from
first of all no one can take america
from you
that is one of the single dumbest things
i've ever heard coming from the right
oh they're trying to at that end they're
coming to take our guns
[ __ ] how long they've been
coming to take your guns because i'm
pretty sure they've been coming to take
your guns
since like two 1908 or some [ __ ]
you only just you all need to come up
with a new story okay
because if if they haven't taken your
[ __ ] by now
come on man seriously they're coming to
do good girls trust me if the government
wanted your [ __ ]
the government would have your [ __ ] and
you having a stockpile
or plenty of ammo i'm ready for the
government
drone strike [ __ ] you're not
ready for
anything you talk [ __ ] you all talk
so much [ __ ] when you're on i have to
shoot a dude from 5 000 yards okay a
drone can take you out from five [ __ ]
miles dude
okay you are not ready to go toe-to-toe
with united states military
i don't give a [ __ ] how much camo you
have stop
living in this fantasy land i don't care
for your politics trump supporters but i
need you to understand
i love you as human beings i love you as
god's children and i don't want to see
you get
[ __ ] up unnecessarily okay
so do me a [ __ ] favor grab ahold of
this reality
donald trump is no longer your president
critical race theory
simply wants to teach people that racism
inherited
within the system is bad okay
that's it no one wants to take [ __ ]
guns
no one wants to destroy america no one
wants to disband the oak ridge boys
everybody just want [ __ ] to be cool you
[ __ ] tarts
okay have a mayonnaise sandwich put on a
[ __ ] john cougar mellencamp record
and calm the [ __ ] down
okay you people are on my lap i had to
literally go to the nerve bank and take
out a loan
because you [ __ ] are on my last one
okay please stop
with your stupidity i wish you were not
color related i wish you were not white
stupidity but it's white stupidity
please stop hashtag stop
white stupidity if we make that trend
can we make hashtag stop white stupidity
trend
because there are a whole bunch of white
people in this country
who are republican who are conservative
who i do not agree with
politically but who are good people who
do not follow around an
orange [ __ ] who has no idea what
he's talking about
do you people understand that you're
losing this fight
no one's rushing to join you guys
the club is pretty much the club you're
not getting any new members
okay so we'll see you in 2022
and they're going to see you again in
2024 because in 2022 we all know y'all
got [ __ ] to offer
but we tried some [ __ ] and it didn't
work
please vote for us we were stupid and
follow donald trump
we don't have no other choice please
help us
it's so sad okay these people are stuck
like chuck dude republican party is so
[ __ ] done and they
cannot see it and rather than just check
donald trump and say [ __ ] we're
done
because he owns he has the people
he owns the people and as long as donald
trump
owns the people he owns he doesn't own
the republican party he owns the
republican parties
the voters yeah he owes their vote you
know you know what's crazy is is because
i get this comment a lot and i know you
probably do too in your comment feeds
they'll say boy donald trump lives
inside your brain like
no if if he didn't live inside your
[ __ ]
your [ __ ] universe he wouldn't live
in ours he'd be gone
long gone [ __ ] him gone why you all are
talking this [ __ ] about donald trump
losing our brain let me ask a question
because trump reporters i noticed trump
supporters came on all this [ __ ]
are you sorry you voted for biden yet no
no
no no i'm not sorry but i want to ask
trump supporters let me ask you all a
question
when your boy put his blog up
when your boy put his blog up
why didn't you all go see it they took
that [ __ ] down to 30 days
okay do you know why you are giving him
any traffic
squarespace was getting more traffic
than donald trump's blog
you talk about he living in our heads
you only forgot about him just as quick
you all forgot about donald trump so
quick
that man went to talk to you and you
didn't want to hear a thing he had to
say
i mean i don't know how smart it was to
start a blog in 2021
wow
[Laughter]
i got a copy serve account done listen
to me dude
if i still use a lime wire to pull songs
bro stop okay
oh my god yo but he he has
he has decimated that party because
again
it is their constituency that he owns he
does not own the party he owns their
constituency and as long as he owns that
constituency
the republican party will have their
lips pressed firmly to his ass
because he will tell his people don't
vote for this person
they didn't do what i said boo donald
trump said we don't like you
so do you i mean look what look what
look what the [ __ ] happened
to to uh uh liz jaden right
well what do you think though do you
think though that it's
that it's him that it's him um
manipulating his people or do you think
it's like this q anon stuff because
honestly
honestly it's almost like to me
and and i i said this a couple shows ago
that it's that q anon is a cult
and and and it's not you can't it's hard
to separate
trump from q anon and q arm from trump
because i believe that this trumpism
stuff it's really not just him
it's it's it's oh no no no no no no no
it's the idea yeah it's the idea
that's a name you can give to it but no
that the [ __ ] that he participates
in
was around long before he ever rode down
that [ __ ] escalator right right right
well you can't really blame him for any
of it but
he has exacerbated exac is that the
right is that the word
yeah well i think yeah well i think what
what you're getting at there because
i've been saying the same thing is that
he
he is the vehicle that caused this to
happen
and and the reason why is because donald
trump really doesn't believe anything he
doesn't no no no no donald trump has
played a hustler he's right it's all
about
how can i make some money that's right
he's a blank canvas and he was their
blank canvas and they painted all over
that [ __ ]
and they painted him into a corner to
where he has to be pinned
because i believe i believe that donald
trump never controlled his
base they controlled him it was always
the tail wagging the dog because donald
trump
always has to say he always has to say
what they want him to heat what they
want to hear
because if he doesn't they won't like
him and if they don't like him
he will be unwanted and if he's unwanted
it just isn't going to work
rush limbaugh was the same [ __ ] way
same thing rush limbaugh wasn't a leader
rush limbaugh would listen to what his
people
were listening to what his listeners
were saying and then he'd say it and
then regurgitate
it because that's what they wanted to
hear he would say in a microphone what
they wanted to hear
but that's why you know that's and again
you unfortunately you know i should say
not you but we unfortunately live in a
country
where where the popul okay
and this is the part we have to be
honest about because i'm not
particularly happy to say this about
a lot of my fellow americans but it
needs to be said
we got some dumb [ __ ] in this
country
okay you got people super stupid i want
you to remember ladies and gentlemen
this is the country
where the pet rock grossed 15 million
dollars 15 million dollars somebody took
a [ __ ]
rock stuck it in a little crate
called it a pet rock it even came with
instructions on how to train your
[ __ ] rock
you think black people were buying pet
rocks no
white people were buying pad rocks do
you think black people were buying the
invisible dog on a leash you remember
the invincible dog leash
do you think anybody would black you
mean at the state fair at the state fair
any black person was literally walking
their invisible dog through the [ __ ]
hood
no that has never [ __ ] happened
because god loved you white america but
you are gullible as [ __ ]
you are gullible as [ __ ] i swear to god
there's still people that believe
blair which is true it's the american
don't
know don't get me wrong that was a hell
of an ad campaign
that was a hell of an ad campaign well i
mean make em make make witches great
again right
i watched that movie in broad daylight
it still stirred the [ __ ] out of me
right
it was it was a great play but i i i
just
so let me so let me ask you another
because because i want to yeah i want i
want
a few more of your opinions on those
things which have to do with this
but uh you know we've seen just
yesterday
uh the the hr what was hr one
uh the the for the people act right to
the senate moved to the committees
it was going to the floor to be debated
they were going to vote for it to be
debated and of course
uh in in great great republican style
they use the filibuster
a racist archaic procedure really that
has only been used to
uh oppress people and
and they used it in great fashion to
oppress
people's vote and they blocked the for
the people act for now i believe
uh it will come back to the floor i
believe that there's going to be
pressure to do this
but i want to see what your opinion is
on not not just
because i think i think the idea of them
blocking the debate
actually pushes it forward more than it
i think if they voted to just debate it
it may have it may have died but now
that they've done this
it pissed people off so but but i
want to get your opinion more about some
of these laws that are in these states
and and explain to people
why when someone says well that's not
racist
why why it's [ __ ] racist when when
you're when you're passing laws
like you know you're not going to keep a
polling place open late
when you know you have people of color
who work a certain you know
workers or job they can't get off in
time the place is going to be close the
idea that you're going to have the same
amount of ballot boxes
in in a county that has one million
people in the same county that has
you know 200 000 people holy [ __ ] dude
really
are you literally trying to make it
harder for you you know
what's going to make it harder for black
people to vote because you know
historically black people had to wait
longer to vote
so you're just going to make that harder
to do the very idea that
you could be arrested for giving someone
water and
food for standing online to vote if that
is not proof of what the republican
party
is trying to do because you all can't
even defend that
you you can't even you can't even begin
to defend them you can't defend half of
these
these laws that you guys have in here
and and
and and yet you're going to try to push
them through because you're still trying
to placate donald trump
you're still trying to please donald
trump and donald trump is is
is telling his people oh he's going to
i'll be back in august i'll be president
again in august
and and if
and this is my one of my biggest
problems that i have with the democrats
right now it's like
are you all gonna
are you just gonna scold them and you
know hope they have a a a
attack of conscience or you know because
if you're waiting for the republican
party to be a shame
brother it is so [ __ ] late
we are long ways we are having so far
away from them having any kind of
[ __ ]
be able to hang their head down and be
ashamed because you again
they are actively engaging in corrupt
activity you know
in front of our very eyes and they're
not apologizing for it they're
they're trying to get it done as quickly
as they possibly [ __ ] can well and i
i think that's actually the danger here
for 2022 is that timing that you're
talking about because
man they're ramming these laws through
yeah they're ramming these [ __ ]
through
and and the reason why i think it's so
critical right now
and if anyone's out there listening to
what that strategy is
for anyone who wants people to have the
right to vote and everyone to have the
same chance to vote what you need to do
is you need to not only pressure not
only pressure
like joe manchin or kristen cinema who
could
kill the filibuster and get this bill to
the floor but you need to be
you need to be talking and yelling and
screaming at your local
representative your representative your
senator your
person you need to find their phone
number you need to you need to
lock up their [ __ ] voicemail you need
to lock up their inboxes
you need to be pounding your
representative because
if if the person who represents you goes
holy [ __ ] these people are serious about
this because let's get
let's get this clear let's get this
clear
in this country there's 50 republican
senators
there's 50 democrat senators the only
reason why there's a majority leader
that's a democrat is because kamala
harris is the vice president united
states and she's a democrat
and she is the breaking thai boat now
the problem with that the problem with
that
is 50 senators
50 democrat senators democratic senators
is that the 50 democratic senators
represent
40 million more people
fifth it's split half and half
and the democrats represent 50
mi 40 excuse me 40 million more people
which
that is why people when they say this
country is divisive
it's divided no it's not it's not
i mean yeah sure we're divided between
the people who want to govern and the
people who don't
right sure but the reason why there's
such stress
is because the majority isn't ruling
and the majority wants to rule that's
what they
want but that's what it's supposed to be
well and i think that's what this
i think that's where we're working
towards and you know there's always
growing pains like you were saying with
change when you get real change it hurts
because when you get real change you're
changing someone's outlook
and they're you know what their comfort
zone is
right so when you get real change it
does hurt and this is this is why this
is hurting
so let's move on to the next thing
before we we get going because i i
really want to talk about
because i think this is some of the most
important news that came out of
washington in the last week
you know we seen the january 6
commission die in the senate
right uh the one that the house passed
uh
it was going to be a quote-unquote
bipartisan
911 style commission where there wasn't
going to be current
election and how could anybody have a
problem with that
well especially if antifa and black
lives matter
and the fbi now were the cause of the
january 6 insurrection
i need to make a video about that also
also also i need to know
all i need to know is are we taking bets
on when they start
when they start blaming planned
parenthood for the insurrection
because because they've went through
they went through all the groups
i'm just waiting on them to blame
planned parenthood i don't it's probably
some conspiracy about
uh you know it was abortion it was
antifa blm
fetuses yes that's probably you you got
a good point
you got a good point make sure to get
that in the tick tock when you make it
um but but so so the biggest news about
the january 6 commission is it died in
the senate
the the 911 style commission so what
nancy pelosi the word is the rumbling is
is that the house is going to create a
benghazi type committee a select
committee
to investigate this thing which i think
this is actually what republicans want
and the reason why they want a benghazi
style hearing
is because it'll be majority democrats
because majority have our democrats have
the majority in the house
so it'd be ruled by so they can say oh
it's another witch hunt
it's another democratic witch hunt right
it's like right again you [ __ ]
had every and again
every opportunity how many times did
y'all go to court
how many times did you go to court i
know you went to the supreme court at
least twice
well as far as criminal court i don't
think they're done yet with all this
we've got the evidence we've got the
evidence where's the evidence
well michael it's in it's in the my
pillow guys pillowcase
don't you know yeah he's got mike
lindell has got a pillowcase full of
evidence you would
you would love to see it i would love to
see it except it doesn't exist and in
two weeks you'll know
it not the time i get my health
right right yeah yeah well i mean we're
you know
we'll all should be done in about two
weeks easy on the easy on the truth
thing
okay i want to tell you because because
we're
we're running we got about eight minutes
left so i want to tell you
i i want to thank you for coming on the
show today and i appreciate it bro
i'm sorry about the technical thing no
no don't don't worry i can talk
i can talk for six hours uninterrupted
yeah without without skipping a beat
that's why i had to come on a podcast
instead of tick tock 60 seconds was just
not it's not gonna get my [ __ ] out
yeah i might i may have to do the same
thing so that's right
so i really appreciate you joining us
and you're always welcome back
always thank you brother i appreciate it
and the next time because i know
because your your ted cruz song went
viral right
it went pretty viral yeah it went pretty
violent you got you got you got a lot of
views on that
your your your juneteenth so the next
time you have a viral video
maybe maybe it'll be like a the the
michael j
viral guest type thing because i know
it's
i know it'll be incendiary so it'll be
perfect for the [ __ ] podcast
absolutely oh yeah oh yeah and i i i i
i i you'll you'll see oh yes you'll see
me wearing this in way more videos
if anyone if anyone wants the vodka mats
like michael j's got on
uh they are available in gray and black
uh i gotta get a great one [ __ ] you
didn't do it
i didn't have multiple coaches right
well you you pick black you gotta get a
great one
you usually wear black hats though oh
god yes oh god yeah yeah okay
so oh my my the mrs wants one oh okay
all right all right well here's here's
what i'll tell you i have some news on
the hat situation
the news is is that we're not only gonna
have black and gray
uh i was trying to do like a red white
and blue for fourth of july
nice yeah but but the hat situation with
the coronavirus and supply is
is is not great so but what i did was is
i ordered
flex fits hats like this the nice hats
um there's gonna be blue and there's
also going to be red available
so we're going to make red hats wearable
again
that's that's my goal is to make red
hats wearable again so
red hat's wearable so so in a couple
weeks
we'll have black gray blue and red so
look out for that go to
thetonymichaels.com or
hats.dtonymichaels.com we got a new hat
store that
that's up and running so any any any of
the money that you do the hats
gives me the ability to get people like
at one black man's opinion on here to
give his opinion
and i think i think we got his opinion
today i'm not really
sure maybe yeah you might i might have i
might have shared yeah
i mean really next time you come on you
should really tell us exactly what
you're thinking
a little bit yeah i know i know it's
hard to
it's hard it's hard to really get opened
up on a show like this
yes yes man i really i really do
appreciate you joining me sorry for the
for the technical difficulties and the
time
you're in a different time zone yeah but
it was all of mine and i got you in any
[ __ ] time bro
anytime you want me to go good thank you
sir and and
and i know i know everyone out there
will be interested in clips
so i'll make some clips for for michael
j to put on this tic tac
so you guys should see you yelling and
screaming no i want a copy
you know you gotta say i'll get you i'll
get you some good clips
and maybe maybe i'll maybe cut them up
and make them real funny too
that way you got a good one and i'll put
some on mine and i'll tag you
i appreciate you thank you very much mr
michael j we will talk to you soon
i'll talk to you soon we'll have you
back on here so get get to making the
next viral video we need to have the
i i'm on it right now i'm going to all
right buddy we'll talk to you soon
at one mac at one black man's opinion
michael j everybody thank you
we'll put the links up for his for where
to follow him thanks mike
excellent thanks bud all right
what did you think so i knew i knew he
would eventually get back
uh to where his technical difficulties
weren't as
uh a trouble and we got him on a podcast
we got his opinion
everyone loves well not everyone i mean
trump bumpers hate
michael j and there are some liberals
that that do not like
at one black man's opinions opinion but
you know that's that's how it goes so we
went through the
the the jude video we went through
critical race theory
we went through the word [ __ ] the voting
rights today
and the pelosi committee again if i
appreciate you joining us on a podcast
if you'd like to support the podcast you
can go to thetonymichaels.com
uh we've got stickers there in the merch
store again we got the hats like michael
j was talking about look out for the red
and blue ones coming i know i'll
probably do some videos
uh to let you guys know when we do get
the red and blue ones in stock and on
the website
uh i was gonna try to do a red white and
blue one for the fourth of july
uh the ones that they were offering were
kind of cheesy
uh i i didn't like that i don't want a
cheesy hat i i wanted a serious hat so
what we did was we went for the red and
blue flex fits
like i wear so be looking for the red
and blue flex fits on the website
and you know what come join us next week
because i'm sure there's going to be all
kinds of craziness i'm trying to get
another guest on next week from
another tick tocker another tick tocker
a grown man tick tocker well i always
get that why are you're a grown ass man
why are you on tick tock
well why are you a grown ass man
commenting on my tick tock
you dumb [ __ ] what the hell
i'm on tick tock and you're here too
commenting
so why am i the [ __ ] bag because i'm
making videos
you're just mad that my video triggered
your dumb ass
you [ __ ] snowflake so
i'll see you next week wednesday
remember wednesday
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern youtube
twitch and we stream on twitter hi
twitter
and when it's done recording you guys
can go back to youtube and watch it
it's not gonna go anywhere and matter of
fact when i get off here what i do is i
go
and i put the audio on apple podcast
and spotify in any of your your podcast
directories wherever you want to find it
that way you can go listen to it in case
you don't want to you know admire my
beautiful face you can just listen to my
beautiful voice
so join us next week three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern on
wednesday
and until then because it's
constitutional to not only write it but
say it and put it on social media
[ __ ] em you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime
follow tony on social media at the tony
michaels
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after me
[ __ ] them